[Music]
[Applause]
Reggie Miller the Hall of Famer Finals
game five tonight 8 30 Eastern on ABC in
Denver I'm checking the math here reg
and I know you said the Miami Heat and
sticks I don't think that they can win
in six
I don't think they can win in six I felt
like something special was brewing in
Miami it just so happened that big face
coffee that Jimmy Butler is so
effectually known for right uh I just
think that's what the Nuggets were
drinking with their chicken McNuggets
okay
well look just looking at this series
um
at the end of the day Denver
they've been much more physical after
that berating by their coach after game
two
they're just bigger they're stronger at
every position even looking at uh
Christian Brown uh Off the Bench he's
bigger than
you know a lot of the starters for Miami
cream Rises and they will they've always
had the best player in the series on the
floor
in yogic and the two best players though
reg what a crazy stat you just gave
because you what series was that for
Michael Jordan where he had four
straight games of 10 what series was
that of his sixth finals appearances
because you never I never would have
guessed that yeah magic not that he
wasn't a willing pastor but I I didn't
think he would have had four straight
games like that yeah magic did it five
times Jordan and Koozie did it uh once
with at least four consecutive finals
games with ten or more assists so uh
maybe uh my research Department can look
and see what seriously even answering
any of your questions so I don't know if
he's gonna do any kind of research oh
yeah we'll even answer your question yes
Paul yeah I got it it's a 1991 NBA
Finals versus the Lakers Jordan had
games with uh 12 13 13 and 10 assists
against the Lakers I wonder if Mike was
like you know magic you're known for
passing the ball I can do what you do
I you know what uh when he was taking
over the Rings as being the best player
that was a part of it because everyone
always said
with magic it was Larry they're winners
they do everything they get everyone
involved and Michael early on in his
career was just known primarily as just
being a scorer so yeah I think in the
back of his mind in the finals against
Magic
I'm going to beat you and what everyone
perceives to be your strength and that
is Distributing the basketball as well
as scoring what can the heat do to make
this competitive
they've got these undrafted guys who
have been fantastic throughout this
playoff line the Duncan Robinsons they
gave Vincent's the Caleb Martin's
they've got to score the basketball
that's that's really it and give Denver
uh nuggets credit defensively they shut
these guys down but scoring is at a
premium and Miami plays their best when
their defense is clicking but they get
timely offense we know about Jimmy
Butler and Bam but to me the success of
Miami has been those other guys because
they've been reliable throughout this
playoff run and in the finals
um they kind of been up and down Duncan
Robinson
um who was good in game two has been a
no-show so they've got to find scoring
I brought this up last week that if
Joker wins a championship let's say he
averages a triple double I mean he might
be putting up numbers that are the best
that anybody's ever put up through an
entire postseason
is is he in the conversation he's not
Bill Russell he's not Kareem but is he
entering a conversation with
David Robinson Akeem
I wouldn't put him in there with Shaq
but
uh where where would he be with great
centers of all time
I would say he he would be knocking on
the door I I can't put him in there with
Akeem yet I can't put him in there with
David Robinson because he's going to
have to win another championship
what the numbers he has put up is
historic we've never seen anything like
it before he's somewhat of a unicorn at
the ability to score to assist to
rebound the passes have been phenomenal
for the end of the day it's only one
championship and I know people want to
get caught up in that yeah if he builds
up a body of work and he comes back with
another championship then we can open
the door and start having these
conversations but with one Championship
I can't put him in there with a king who
has two David Robinson I believe has two
or three
um it's very difficult for me to put him
in that company he's nowhere near a shot
in my opinion in terms of Sinners he's
nowhere near shot and um Joker is not I
think he's 28. Akeem didn't have his
titles till he turned 30. and and this a
team that is going to be together
they're young and they just made a trade
with Oklahoma City to get another draft
pick I think a second round draft pick
this upcoming draft you know they're
they're going to want to reload or add
maybe not even reload but add to what
they already have to make sure that
they're still the team to beat next year
and well coast and Michael Malone and
let's remember this experience that goes
a long way and if they can find a way
which we all believe they will uh to
wrap it up tonight and win a
championship that experience and that
ship on your shoulder every time they
take the floor a year from now once next
season kicks in it's taking the floor of
the world champions that kind of Builds
on your ego and your psyche a little bit
and that builds that confidence the team
they're young they're energetic again we
talked about them being well coached
they're going to be around for the Long
Haul but I will say this the West is
loaded to them right so they're they're
gonna on a nightly basis when you have
that Target under your back if there's a
chance
um they're gonna have to be able to
bring it each and every night if I said
you could have Luca
or jokic
I would take Jokers
okay I don't think I'm gonna be even
close in my opinion
um especially for my skills that I'm
gonna put myself like who who could I
benefit and play with the most and it
definitely would be yogic the way he
passes and can score and he's so
unselfish not that Luca isn't he's very
unselfish as well but I mean yogis is
just a different breed he's just
different
we had Malika Andrews on last hour and
she said that uh jokic learned how to
pass by water polo
when he holds the ball up if you watch
water polo that's what it is like he's
racing a lot too yes yes and and side
angles and I mean all like Patrick
Mahomes type angles with his passes uh
and I would also say that about water
polo too that builds your Fitness as
well
um if you've ever been to a water polo
match
a Pepperdine
um the fitness of those athletes is
tremendous especially from the upper
body uh being able to wait in water
um and play above the water
um you could tell that's why he's in
great physical shape as well you didn't
play water polo did you no I didn't
any of those things that uh no water and
Reggie doesn't do it
what was your second best sport
baseball baseball was my first love
I was a much better baseball player
early on in my career until I got to
high school and then the coach at
Riverside Poly wanted me to pitch
because in Little League I was like
Mariano Rivera as a pitcher in Little
League I was unbelievable pitcher but
once I went to Pony and then as you know
the mound Rose once you get to high
school it's further back and the high
school coach was like you know I want
you to pitch and I'm like uh no I want
to play center field she's like no
you're gonna pitch I'm like I'm going to
concentrate on basketball oh he's Reggie
Miller the Hall of Famer joining us by
the way game five tonight the heat are
nine point underdogs and that's 8 30
Eastern on ABC Dame Lillard starts next
season where
I want to say Portland but just looking
and observing all these lives that he
does and conducts and you know you got
Portland fans now saying hey we can get
a bag for dating and he's coming out
saying sign a petition if you want me
out of here
I I want to say he's going to be
somewhere else and I know I think his
destinations were Miami he said no to
Boston
um there was one other place that he
said
that he would Brooklyn
that's it
and it's interesting you know we
mentioned Brooklyn because when we were
doing the Brooklyn Philadelphia series
gained two or three I believe it was or
game four
he was in attendance in Brooklyn and I
was like uh oh let all the conversations
started because I think he would be
great on that team with Cam Johnson
Mikhail Bridges Spencer Dinwiddie I
think they need a closer we talked about
that they need a number one on our team
yeah he would be a Bonafide number one
for uh the Brooklyn Nets I I just don't
they can get a lot for him
they're not going anywhere I'm sorry
they're just not Kyrie Irving uh start
of next season will be where
the Dallas Mavericks
they can offer him the most
um
I say he stays with Dallas
they gave up so much to get him they
can't allow him to they basically
gave away all the defensive players to
attain him
so I I think they've got to open up the
bag and sign Highway
Chris Paul is where opening night
I would love
to see him with the Los Angeles Lakers
he's a free agent unrestrictor for agent
I know his family uh they still live in
the Calabasas area
I think he would be a great fit for them
they had point guard woes down the
stretch as we saw with D'Angelo Russell
I would love to see Chris Paul in the
lake uniform playing alongside his good
friend LeBron James
but what are you getting with a 38 year
old Chris Paul
you just want someone to stabilize and
not beat you
make a timely wide open shot don't turn
the ball over and Be steady the key for
Chris is he's gonna have to stay healthy
and stay healthy when it matters yeah
it's like he has always been to come
April 15th once playoffs start
yeah I just and that's a weird situation
if you're LeBron and you Chris Paul and
you go hey
what are you thinking you just need a
floor General though because LeBron what
if LeBron doesn't want Chris Paul
how awkward is that where is that where
you go man polinka he won't pull the
trigger on this man
uh if you can you know for a bargain
based on price which you can
um I don't think you're gonna get them
for like what is he owe 37 million I
think I think 30.
I think you can because most of that the
sons are going to be on the hook for so
if you can get them at a bargain basic
price yeah but haven't we tried this
with the three stoo you know three stars
there in LA so yeah but he wouldn't be
one of those guys that was counting on
to win games he'll be counting on not to
lose games for you I think
and unless at the end of the day when
healthy he is an unbelievable floor
General he understands how to run a team
he is not going to hurt you
didn't Steve Kerr was there something
about maybe Golden State would be
interested in Chris Paul
it might might just making that up or I
thought there was something that was
there I haven't heard that but I could
see that
him playing alongside the Splash
Brothers and Draymond Green
if healthy
I would like to see that that would cut
that would be fascinating to watch as
well
yeah I don't know uh Miami Heat have
no chance or low chance
uh low chance I will I'll never say no
chance yeah just uh Jimmy Butler can go
crazy
um but it would be beneficial for Denver
you don't want to get on a plane go back
to Miami for game six
handle your business because if those
Shooters get going
Miami's been the underdog these whole
post Seasons they barely made it with
that win over Chicago
uh they just smacked Miami or Milwaukee
the number one team in the East
um their most competitive series up to
date before Denver what to me was that
uh Nick series I thought the Knicks
played them pretty well yeah
um and then we saw that seven game epic
series with Boston winning on the road
so they've been there before but I I
just think they're facing a much bigger
more physical
at every position they are Aaron Gordon
played like he did in game one uh in in
game four he just used his size he he
overpowered and On Any Given night one
of those guys can take over led by their
two stars in the old kids and Murray uh
we had a poll question
would you rather be Djokovic
or Drew Brees so greatest tennis player
or most decorated tennis player or would
you rather be Drew Brees with a Super
Bowl win and you know a top 10
quarterback of all time
um wow
are you taking away football which is
the number one sport in the world with
ratings and and all that or the great
arguably the greatest tennis player yeah
I like
I like know about I would take the
arguably one of the greatest tennis
players of all time okay what about your
career if I said you could have your
career or Novak Djokovic
I'm always going to take my career over
and over everybody
I love like I said your career Tom
Brady's
you just told me you're always taking
you
look I'm happy with my career my
ups and downs it's it's the building
blocks it's the building blocks
what about Ray Allen's career or
djokovic's career
Ray had a really good career
greatest shooter besides Steph Curry
[Laughter]
is Ray a better shooter than you okay
stop it here you go
go y'all okay I spawned the ball but
Steph is a better shooter than you
look at my children okay so Ray Allen or
or rayon or Djokovic
uh how about pays your story no no no
okay Robert ory's career or Novak
Djokovic oh uh Novak okay all right
and Rey is it's Steph then Ray
look at this dude
first of all there's Larry Bird he's the
God I'm Jesus and then the rest are my
angels the rest are our Angels so it
goes Larry Legend
as God
Jesus
yours truly and then our angels are
below us oh so so Larry spawned you yeah
exactly that's exactly what I'm saying
well Reggie's got the heat in six
[Laughter]
uh you were you were that close yourself
they come back if they come back you're
going to look good remember low chance
not no chance thank you reg I appreciate
you Theodore regi Aloysius Miller Jr III
game five tonight at 8 30 Eastern on ABC